it's another place we're gonna sensor
Ronaldo is out after setting the record
straight on Manchester United tonight
I'll set the record straight on the
interview that's Rock sporting world the
director from Graham sunes and David
Seaman Arsenal God of course and it's
all live Republic has rushed to run to
santis after their meltdown in the
midterm he's Donald Trump now too toxic
to run again whilst one of his top
advisers an oscar-winning actor Cuba
Gooding Jr's career is in Ruins after
many groping a woman now he wants a
second chance I'm interviewing him
exclusively but is there any Road to
Redemption for the metoo men Superstar
feminist lawyer Gloria Allred for join
me live for the beta
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening from another
welcome to Piers Morgan on Center well
it's not been a quiet few days that's it
the goat has bolted Cristiano Ronaldo
out at Old Trafford after using his
bombshell interview with me on this show
just at the record straight about what
was going on at the club and his
concerns or tonight I'm going to set the
record straight myself on Cristiano
Ronaldo and on that interview because
one week on is still making Global
headlines
breaking news Cristiano Ronaldo's time
at Old Trafford officially over
Manchester United saying that they have
mutually parted ways effective
immediately all of their stems from that
explosive interview with Piers Morgan
Cristiano Ronaldo has left Manchester
United with immediate effect it follows
a TV interview with Piers Morgan where
he claimed he felt disrespected and then
that explosive interview that he had
with Piers Morgan saying those uh very
hurtful things about Manchester United
and after an explosive interview with
Piers Morgan the writing seemed to be on
the wall
like I said it was explosive well this
Show's been at the center of a true
Global story and that story really is
only just beginning because minutes
after Ronaldo confirmed he'd leave
United by Mutual consent the Glazer
family who own the club confirm they're
looking to sell American Family bought
Manchester United for 1.3 billion
dollars in 2005. now they may get four
times that amount and if that sounds
like good business well it is for them
but that's precisely why United fans
have such a problem with the glazes who
loaded United with debt and presided
they're a steady but massive decline on
the pitch they seem more concerned about
selling shirts and shares than winning
Trophies the opposite of what English
football should be about this is what
Ronaldo himself said to me about the
glazes
the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional uh sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion
the funds are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
so did Ronaldo's condemnation of the
glazes force the issue after years of
process by supporters you can judge that
for yourself when the biggest superstar
in the club's history calls out
mismanagement at the very top how could
their position be tenable supporters and
Club Legends like Roy Keane and Gary
Neville have also slammed the glazes
never even called on Ronaldo to use his
status to put them under pressure stand
up now and speak he wrote this summer
The Club is in crisis it needs its
leaders to lead Ronaldo's the only one
who can grab a situation from other
Scruff the neck exclamation mark So
Ronaldo did speak out and the same Gary
Neville said he should be saved
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah Alex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero nothing changed surprisingly
natural only the pulled the jacuzzi even
the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which as I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
we see many
things that I'm used to see when I was
20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
well 13 years after a spectacular first
battle United Ronaldo returned to find a
club but had only gone backwards in his
View and that's the real reason he
wanted to do this interview in the first
place he just had enough and he felt he
wasn't getting the respect that his
extraordinary career deserved and all
the fans getting what they deserve for
supporting United week in week out last
season Ronaldo scored 24 goals for
teaming total turmoil one Premier League
goal more than Harry Kane England's
Captain who is considered one of the top
Strikers in the world right now but
still they blamed Ronaldo his own coach
Eric tenhao disrespected him repeatedly
in public journalists cashed in on the
status for click bait many of the story
is completely untrue Ronaldo soaked all
this up for a long time even though many
of the stories about him were false and
hurtful
and I'm also the Malay that he skipped
pre-season training to force a transfer
when in fact his baby daughter was sick
in hospital just months after her twin
brother had tragically died
Ronaldo told me the executives of the
club didn't even believe him
I wonder he felt very little loyalty to
them in return well now this chapter in
his record-breaking career is over many
people have accused me of using Ronaldo
speculating that he must surely regret
ever sitting down with me in fact the
opposite is true he's very happy with
everything about the interview he said
what he wanted to say and he spoke
because he wanted to speak it takes to
be repeatedly this week all good as we
said on Friday when it finally all add
as he's in Doha now in Qatar to Captain
Portugal at the World Cup the future is
great he says that I reckon for him it
probably will be even at 37 he's a mega
star the biggest icon in football
history with half a billion Instagram
followers but that in context 130
million more than his nearest rival
Lionel Messi his rival for everything
we're not as a merchandising monster or
make a fortune whichever Club you signs
for they fit a Gold machine too you
don't go from scoring 24 goals last
season to a terrible striker in four or
five months
there's been a lot of knee-jerk reaction
from some United fans I mean he's
trashed his legacy at the club really
literally one of the greatest ever ever
put on a United shirt you were lucky to
have him lucky to watch him show him a
bit more respect
Ronaldo once like a penny to leave he's
foregone any of his remaining 17 million
pounds left on his deal all he wants is
his freedom and to go and try his luck
somewhere else where he hopes he'll be
given more respect and if his legacy is
ultimately to get rid of the glazes from
Manchester United English football all
those people criticizing now will
probably be cheering him and saying
thank you Cristiano
another football subject of football and
thanks my sincere thanks also go to the
first team that manages to get through a
day of this tournament without a
pathetic piece of virtue signaling
today it was the Germans you might have
been following this increasingly
ludicrous debate over whether people
should wear armbands to show their
support for the LGBT community
full disclosure I'm completely
supportive of All lgbtq rights always
happening
but I never understood this whole thing
about the armband I want players to play
football the World Cup not a virtue
signal and it's all gone exactly how I
predicted which is that actually when
they were threatened for the first time
with the booking which is someone waving
a yellow card at them
they've all capitulated the German team
today
did this
I mean really this is to send a point to
FIFA that they've been silenced they've
been gagged they can't wear their
armbands oh get over yourselves
it's honestly embarrassing
England have been embarrassing about
this the captain Harry Kane was going to
wear his armband show his great support
for the community okay we'll do it then
we're armband
don't then bottle it because you might
get a yellow card
if any player right now
at the World Cup where is one of these
armbands which I don't think they should
be doing anyway because I don't think
it'll achieve anything
any one of them did it right now and got
a bookie they'd be Global Heroes
probably get Knighthood
but none of them have got the balls
listen to Ray Winston one of my favorite
actors about what he said about this
today
Harry you can't let them tell you what
to do
it probably sends you off and if they do
imagine if Harry Kane got sent off for
wearing an armband supporting one love
all hell would break loose and not at
him he'd be a hero around the world
so then bottle it honestly embarrassing
for Harry for England for the fa and for
the Germans to do what they did today
and he I keep thinking if you don't
focus on the football you know what
happens Germany got beaten
by Japan that's what happens when you're
more worried about
shh than you are about stopping goals
flying in the back of your net well
fortunately I have in my company someone
who knows all about bulls flying in the
back of the net because he stopped most
of them he stopped most of them ever
doing it the greatest goalkeeper to ever
grace to give a football in the world
but numb Arsenal Legend England Legend
David safehand Steven what an honor to
have the great man with me David welcome
to you and from uh uh Qatar Liverpool
former Liverpool manager calls Grand
souness and a presenter from the United
stand podcast Adam who already looks
like he's throwing daggers at me it's
going to be a lively encounter with him
about what he thinks has happened to his
Club following this uh Ronaldo with you
can I get him to thank Cristiano by the
end for getting rid of the glazes it'll
be a tough gig but we'll see how we get
on um let me start with you David
I don't want to talk about armbands I'm
done with armbands I've said my bit
about that I want to talk to you about
Cristiano Ronaldo because it is the
dominant story in World sport it's a
double sorry it's a dominant thank you
see you see immediately he immediately
catches it do you see the way you smoked
it was you that dropped this is why
these legends never lose it unbelievable
I just tested him look at that oh he's
swept and put it back on that's what
he's going to say about it
um it's interesting you famous some
great players yeah you know from Dennis
birkam to others
what this start from the interview
itself if you'd been in a dressing room
one of the top players Thierry Omri
Dennis Bergkamp Tony Adams if one of
them had come out and done this
an interview like this what would your
reaction have been I would be I would
applaud him because he's obviously he's
talking the truth and it's not the the
story a lot of the stuff that he came
out with wasn't stuff that we haven't
heard yeah you know we've heard a lot of
other experienced players moaning is
criticizing man united for for the way
that the ground is the way that the
training that it was really interesting
when he said about the training ground I
was really
I couldn't believe it the the training
around at Carrington was the same as
when he left what was it 15 so years ago
and that really shocked me um because he
you know I Arsenal I go in there every
week now and and I see the Improvement
that they've done you know they've had
an 18 million pound refund and he was
comparing it to what he experienced at
Real Madrid and Juventus exactly where
he said they would evolve all the time
constant new technology new diet new
nutrition he wasn't having a pop-up the
chefs at United so they pop up the food
they're all preparing he couldn't
believe that they were just having the
same stuff they were given 12 years
before yeah and like I said that shocked
me and that that shouldn't be happening
and like say he's been all around the
world and seen how every West progressed
and then he comes back to his beloved
Man United
and nothing he has no regrets whatsoever
about doing the interview I mean I've
spoken to him throughout the week he's
absolutely happy he's glad he's got his
freedom he's glad it's over albeit he
still loves Manchester United as a club
and he loves the fans and he doesn't
want any ongoing issue with them and I
suspect they'll calm down every time I
did when Roy Keane did the same thing
yeah man united TV but should he have
done the interview do you think
I I would say yeah because he put his
side over you know there was a lot of
stuff in the interview that I saw that I
didn't know about I didn't know about
other way that he's been treated you
know the stuff that was going on there
ten hug you know the fact that you know
he you know it's taking for instance the
substitution when he refused to go on
you know as a footballer he should never
do that you know you've got you've got
to like say that he had reason the week
before yeah you know where he was he was
told I'm not putting you on because I
respect you too yeah so next week he's
thinking well he no longer respects me
otherwise nobody want me to come on I
want to play a clip before getting
Graham's sooner so this is a Roy Keane
today it was the first time he's had a
chance to address Ronaldo leaving United
he doesn't know what he said
obviously the uh the interview was a
Tipping Point for him but I
that's it you know life goes on man
united a great Club Ronaldo's a great
player as you said it's like a divorce
it's like the end of a relationship
we don't know how that feels and you go
your separate ways Life Goes On
great great player for Man United should
have probably left in the summer yeah
but that's the player's fault or the
clubs it was never going to happen the
new manager was never going to play him
he cannot have Ronaldo as a sober Fringe
player he's just it's just not right
just not right
and it's it's it's sad
but these things happen
Sooners thank you very much indeed for
joining me again obviously this is a
fast moving story and things have moved
on again from when we last spoke
Ronaldo's now gone glazes may be selling
up pretty tumultuous stuff over at
United but when you listen to what Roy
Keane said there
I mean that to me I think he's right
about you know this stuff happens and
it's time to move on what did he say
Pierce
are you saying you sat on the fence a
bit
yeah I think which is very unusual for a
ride yeah we sat there and and said that
he's a great player he's been a great
servant and um
not a lot else he did go on to say that
he felt that he'd be mismanaged Ronaldo
which is kind of what you've said as
well about this but now I would say I
would say I would say
I would certainly agree with that my
take is the same take on it as the exact
same as when we spoke before when I was
on your show I think um
the two of them got together when
Ronaldo stated he wanted to leave in the
summer the two of them go in a room with
him and the manager they come out that
room two people leave the room and two
of them are satisfied with what they've
agreed
they lose to Brighton the lose to
bramford and all of a sudden is chaos at
man united I think the manager panicked
his coaching staff panicked we need not
so much a victim but we need to analyze
where we're going wrong I think they've
come up with the wrong analysis I think
they've looked at we can't press with
Ronaldo and our team
now my take on it as a football person I
don't believe Ronaldo
even in 37 I don't think man united can
be doing without Ronaldo at this time in
their development where they want to be
I think it's been a
an enormous case of
mismanagement I think it's an enormous
case of lack of
speaking to each other communication
if the manager and the staff have
decided after two games because I've
lost two games
we're going to go a different route
after having agreed with Ronaldo before
any games are played they had to
communicate that to Ronaldo because what
happened after that was you've you've
touched already
they don't bring them on against Man
City that's come to go on against
Tottenham a week after that or 10 days
after that that's going to be Captain
they are really mixed messages for a
player to accept yeah and when the word
disrespect was used by Ronaldo I think
that's saying that someone has gone back
on their words
and who can it be it can only be the man
united manager right he has changed
whatever he said before a ball was
kicked so where he got to the situation
where he came out made his statement
with you disrespect I think someone's
not someone's changed their minds on it
yeah I think you're right well let's go
to Adam's stop uh presenter of the
United States and I think that's where
anger comes from right Pierce I have to
say that I think the stuff about
swimming pools and kitchen
that really doesn't come into the
argument why he's leaving man united
he's leaving man united because he still
feels he's a football nut we know that
yeah look at him he's a specimen there
is not out there and I've said this
again there's out there there's not a
better example you could have in your
dressing room surely you want to keep
that man united are country mile away
from where they need to be is it you
know the great football club that they
are they ain't going to be one of the
European the Champions League anytime
soon they will not be winning the
Premier League anytime soon Ronaldo is a
role model you'd have to explain this to
him I want you here because this that
and that him is a role model you could
not name me a better one in the history
of football right not in this generation
in the history of football yeah for me I
would have fought to keep up I would
have pleaded with them to stay because I
need you if you're a young fella in that
dressing room
prior to Ronaldo turning up
who do you look in the dresser and say
in 10 years time I want to be like him
so Ronaldo turns up everyone in the
dress room says in 10 years time I want
to be like him I think it's a girl I
think it's a mistake in letting them go
but time will tell interesting stuff uh
Graham thank you let's go to Adam stop
well Adam look don't listen to what I
have to say about this I'm an Arsenal
fan I don't really care how tumultuous
things get at United but I'm also an
interviewer and I sat with Ronaldo and
he gave me his side in his eyes he was
correcting a lot of untruths that have
been said about him so it was more a
repost if you like or a bottle of a lot
of things
um as a United fan what's your feeling
about all this
yeah I mean I look at I'm listening to
what Graham said there at the start of
the season and Ronaldo in your interview
Pierce went on about the start of the
Season no pre-season was why and he
understood why he didn't start the
season but in the Brighton game he
played 37 minutes the Brentford game he
played the full nine set we lost both of
them games it wasn't a knee-jerk
reaction we just went back to basics 10
hag went to the training ground and
fought up a different plan Ronaldo
didn't start the next four games the
next four games Manchester United won
and turned their season around a manager
has to make a decision for the better of
the team and if that doesn't involve
Cristiano Ronaldo at that time then
that's down on the manager and it worked
for the manager people will be in over
the top with 10 hacks team selection for
the Liverpool game I remember talking to
Graham sunes just on the eve of that
game with the protests and game soon has
fought that the protest would be a
hindrance on Manchester United going
into that game it didn't it the crowd
came to together and they got behind the
team and that team didn't have Cristiano
Ronaldo in it the fans got behind
whoever was on that picture wanted to
give it 100 and there is a general
consensus we're in the united fan base
Ronaldo hasn't been giving that 100
whether that be for his opinion on how
he's been treated the fans are seeing
what's going on the pitch more we don't
see everything on behind the scenes
obviously but what counts is what
happens on the pitch and he hasn't been
performing this season in particular and
the team is playing better without
Ronaldo
you say that um I'm in a blissful
position of Arsenal being top of the
league by five points and and 11 points
clearer of United you've got to go to
the playoffs now against Barcelona beat
you without Ronaldo right you got to get
to the playoffs against Barcelona Europa
League which you may lose
um I'm not quite sure this constitutes a
great Revolution so far ten hog is
completely unproven outside of Holland
and I might the point that Graham made
which really resonated with me and I
think I know the answer is that if
you're in that dressing on why wouldn't
you see him as the greatest role model
has ever been actually one of the big
big concerns Ronaldo had was unlike him
when he walked into that dress room as
an 18 year old and saw skulls and gigs
and keen and Ferdinand and wanted to
soak all he could offer them in terms of
experience and expertise a lot of these
young United players earn too much money
and don't care and didn't really want to
do that with him I found that staggering
yeah no I can understand that side of it
and when Ronaldo did that interview one
of the many few he did last season
saying that the younger player didn't
want to take his advice I was fully on
board with that the problem that we've
had with Ronaldo is the fact we didn't
think he should have done the interview
with yourself person the way it was he
was on the contracts at Manchester
United he talked about the times have
changed since Relic Ferguson left the
football club I guarantee he wouldn't
have done this interview with yourself
if Alex Ferguson was still manager of
the football club it's the it's what
we've seen as like going behind the
manager's back the fans support the
manager we support the manager he's the
biggest man at this football club famous
words that came out of Sir Alex
Ferguson's mouth and that's who the fans
will be behind well you're supporting
him about yeah you'll support him until
you get rid of him like the last few
you've had I mean let's be honest every
manager since Ferguson has had your
Universal support United fans right to
the point they've been slung out that's
been part of the problem
um but look uh Graham you've been
shaking your head listening to of this
do you want to respond no no I I sorry
what's this what's the chat the United
States
hi Adam Adam I think you know what what
you what you said a lot of it is correct
it's a manager it's a manager's decision
to to go to a different route if he
feels he's he's Tim are not at it it's
not working his game plan but where I'm
coming from
I think he has to communicate that to
Ronaldo listen we had that conversation
I think that's the word disrespect
sticks in my head yeah that's saying
someone by Dieter words is not carried
carried through and what they're either
going to do or say and I think they had
an agreement two games later the manager
has changed and gone down a different
route that that is a manager's
prerogative but I think at that time
it's not been from that I said looking
and I don't know anything that's not
being communicated
to Ronaldo because if I had been
communicated to Ronaldo I don't think
the word disrespect would come out and I
and I and I and I think
you said you turned the season round I
think turned around from the first two
games that you lost picked up a few
points but I I've been in dressing rooms
I I constantly see on on when I'm on
television that you cannot be successful
as a manager stock coach unless you've
got good senior Pros that is a fact of
life as I see it and I think as born if
you look at the clubs that have been
successful you look at your Club over
the years is a perfect example yeah it
keeps Gary Neville a couple years
I'm going to go and have dinner with
them after this it kept carrying
everything maybe two years long two
years longer than you should have done
Paul scholes left and brought him back
he kept getting Ryan gigs onto his about
35-36 because they had good senior Pros
we made sure people turned up on time to
improperly they're at every day in
training and their attitude to games
when it mattered you need good senior
pros and I come back to you could not
get a better example of a good Senior
Pro than Ronaldo yeah and also when when
when
he was sent to chamber the kids the word
is he was now on perfect the way he
trained with the kids I heard that so I
come back to you cannot have enough good
senior Pros Ryan I've gotta I'm gonna
leave it there Adam thank you very much
indeed I appreciate it uh final word to
you David
um last night I was sitting next to you
when news broke that Ronaldo was now
available yep and your immediate
reaction
was well we should take him Arsenal the
rest of the season totally I was like
we'd have him and we both agree I
totally agree I even like listened to
Graham there you know he's talking about
Ronaldo he's not he's not done he's far
from done you know and we actually need
a good natural predatory goal it'd be
perfect for Arsenal you know and he'd be
he'll be perfect a lot over the clubs
yes you know where he gets the respect
yeah but you've never heard any players
moaning about Alex or Alex Ferguson no
about a lack of respect no absolutely
right uh We're Gonna Leave You David
Seaman with a replay of your brilliant
save of my pen let's have a look at this
is
so fast
David great to see you really appreciate
it a real honor to have you well next
tonight is it time for Republicans to
dump Donald Trump in America or are we
mad to bet against him because we did
that last time and you know how that
worked
foreign
[Music]
in order to make America great and
glorious again I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for president of the United
States
what is the speech of the growing number
of Republicans hoped you wouldn't make
Donald Trump confirming he will now run
for president again in 2024 even after
many of his anointing candidates flopped
in the midterm elections does he have
any conceivable road back to the White
House but joining me now is Transformers
in reviser Jason Miller former
conservative MP Lord Jeffrey Arch I
conservative commentator Ann Coulter a
wonderful trio trio we're going to Lord
Archer first
um Lord Archer you're a connoisseur of
American politics what do you make of
what's going on there
well it's fascinating in fact I don't
think we've ever seen anything like it
and the comments you made before we came
into this section is don't write the man
off one has to remember uh when he stood
for president for the first time he was
in a debate with Jed Bush among others
and everybody said Bush was going to win
easily he was the most impressive of the
bushes he had all the money he was
governor of California how could he lose
and Bush stole the day so my own view is
until we until we see
who the candidates are and my bet is if
Bush will be there I'm sorry Trump will
be there of course he will but when he
gets up on that stage beware he's quite
capable of beating everybody in sight
and anyone who underestimates him will
be a fool I think that's absolutely
right Jason Miller I mean you know
Donald Trump very well you still speak
to him on a regular basis
the unpredictable element of Donald
Trump is he's a ferociously good
campaigner no question and the way he
saw off all those other candidates on
the Republican nomination ticket back in
2015-16 was unbelievable
yeah absolutely and if you go to his
speech that he gave last week his
announcement speech it was I think this
surprised a lot of people that it was
forward-looking or we didn't have any of
the election grievances there was a much
more Outsider populist angle to it I
think you're going to see his messaging
as very much more the 2015 2016 Donald
Trump as opposed to 2020. how would he
get round the reality that a lot of his
big tips for the midterm elections lost
and the the unifying Factory most of
them was that they buy into this idea
they had the 2020 election stolen well I
interviewed him and it's actually a
great interview with some fractious
moments back in April but when I did I
kept saying Tim if you keep looking back
at 2020 I think you're going to stop
yourself being able to win a game and
he's ignored me but all the candidates
that backed what the Democrats call the
big lie about Islam election most of
them lost
well you had a mixed bag you had some
Trump back candidates who won some that
lost some that weren't Trump back some
of them really high profile ones some of
them but also keep in mind when you look
at some of the Swing States Arizona
Wisconsin Georgia they're very much uh
just on the the head of the needle here
and the general election polling right
now has Trump ahead of Biden in those
three states tied in Pennsylvania so I
think part of the reason on that is
because Trump isn't viewed as the
politician only person to carry the
banner twice in the general election but
then not be viewed as a politician
because he's the outsider that's kind of
his his Mojo his sweet spot as long as
he can do that and stay forward-looking
the economy in the U.S has gotten
terrible well that's I think that's
definitely there's no question about
that and that's going to open up that
gives him the entree Americans were told
two years ago we simply restore some
sensibilities back to the White House be
nice to people no more Mean Tweets
everything is going to be fine well us
has gone to Hell in a hand basket it's
not good let me get around Coulter I
mean and um you you've had your
flirtations with Trump in the past
professionally speaking
um what are your thoughts now about
Trump should he be running again is
there somebody else you think should be
actually the Republican nominee
well it was more than a flirtation uh
after his Mexican rapist speech I was
introducing him at rallies two weeks
later I wrote the book in Trump We Trust
I am an actual
2016 and 2015 Trump supporter I notice a
lot of the people who support Trump now
and think oh it must be magic they they
didn't support him in 2015. they were
never trumpers they didn't understand
that it was his issues it was never his
personality and the analysis that whoa
he shocked the world in 2016. this is a
classic fallacy that people use in the
market to predict what a billion people
or millions of people are going to do
how they're going to invest and it's a
mistake in politics because something
happened once doesn't mean it's going to
happen again we used to always see her
ooh the tallest man always becomes
president yeah it happens until it
doesn't happen but I'd also say even if
the fallacy fallacious thinking were
true because it happened last time this
way it's going to happen next time this
way no I'm sorry that was four times ago
the last three elections Trump lost and
lost big in 2018 once we saw he wasn't
doing anything he said he was going to
do when he was campaigning in 2016. he
lost 40 House Seats okay fine it's a
midterm election in 2020 there was a Red
Wave across the country except for Trump
and as you just mentioned and I'll go
through it chapter and verse it was
Trump that absolutely destroyed
Republicans in these midterm elections
yeah some of the candidates he endorsed
one in Wednesday
give me give me one name of a better
candidate in your eyes
well well right obviously
um governor of Florida Ron DeSantis he
didn't listen to fauci Trump did
yeah I mean look Lord Archer if you if
you look at Rhonda santis he's almost
half Trump's age he's full of Vitality
and energy he's got an amazing uh CV you
know Yale Harvard special Council
advisor to the head of Seal Team one or
two it was in collusion I mean amazing
uh credentials what do you think of him
I think he's very impressive at the
moment we must remember where some time
away and predictions this early can so
often go wrong I certainly would vote
for him at the moment but what will
happen when that debate comes on what
will happen when the real fight starts
don't underestimate Trump I think Ron
DeSantis would make a brilliant
president everything I've seen about him
I like but that doesn't mean he will be
there on the final day I would predict
it on your program appears that that
Trump would never become the Republican
candidate and when you ask me back I
predicted that he'd never become the
president of the United States
totally wrong
it's very you know what Jeffrey it's
very honest of you to admit that because
not many do I was one of the very few
people actually in this country who saw
the Trump train coming in 2015-16 and
predicted he'd win
um yeah okay so just to come back to you
has Donald Trump got the stamina and the
will to do this again he's become come
under such tremendous fire I actually
thought the speech when he when he said
he's running again by his stance a
little bit low energy well he was going
to get hit no matter what he did either
they're going to say he had a little
energy or they're gonna say he was going
to election Grievances and was too wild
and out of control but I so I think he
found the sweet spot with it as far as
the energy goes keep in mind it's not
just in a vacuum he's going against Joe
Biden who comes across as a fossil a
skeleton he does but he has a
surprisingly good midterms I mean one of
the best mid terms he did I mean an
important point Republicans Got 5
million more votes for congressional
candidates we won the house background
it's not a good midterm to the
Republicans not as good not as good as
what about the scientists The Moment I
Saw Trump abusing DeSantis and giving
him nicknames I thought he's worried
about him uh this answer he'll be a
formidable opponent he's going to be
tough DeSantis has a good record of
Governor there's a problem I think for
DeSantis and the fact that the
establishment is already rallying behind
him you see the Ken Griffins you see the
Steve Schwartzman do you see all the
globalist CEOs rushing to his defense
guys they learned nothing from 2016.
they're going to go and get Donald Trump
the primary and the uh well that could
well happen and culture uh there's a
certain football match or soccer as you
people like to call it uh on Friday
England v the U.S
what's going to happen any prediction
um my prediction is Americans will
continue hating soccer
[Laughter]
Jason prediction from you I'll be
cheering for the U.S I'm hosting a big
World Cup party with Matt Leticia the
greatest of all time excited to be with
him I might be the only American who's
there cheering for the U.S team but it's
going to be fun and even though you
might think the US doesn't have a chance
look at Japan look at Saudi Arabia this
is upset season Lord Archer I have a
five thousand dollar bet with Brian
Kilmeade from Fox and Friends in America
the England will not just I think it's
high as he put it so grotesque but it's
obviously a draw but then we will win
convincingly
well I feel very sorry for your two
American guests they're going to be very
lonely that evening because we will win
I don't know five Nils six Nils seven
nil they're rubbish we're the best am I
gonna win
Jeffrey great to see you and Colter
always a pleasure and Jason good to see
you in the studio thank you very much
indeed we're coming next Oscar winning
actor Cuba Gooding Jr is the greatest
his reputation into tattoos now he wants
a second chance and he sat down with me
for his first television interview to
explain why
foreign
[Music]
movement began in Hollywood sparked a
near Global Reckoning with the
unreasonable sexual behavior as so many
powerful men oscar-winning actor Cuba
Gooding Jr recently faced his
comeuppance emitted in court that he
forcibly touched a woman in New York
club and his career could be over he
believes he deserves a shot of
redemption and he sat down with me for
an exclusive interview first Kelsey
Harbor was his victim
the one thing I was promised in the end
was an apology
despite the harm to me Cuba Gooding Jr
walks away from the court of free Man
Without a record
it's like it never happened
but can the same thing be said for the
women he did this to
is it like it never happened to me
so the first thing I'll say is what I
already did and I apologize to all my
fans but the second thing is truth
truth Pierce this video footage of it
there was no contact with her breast
that's the truth the other impact
statement of the other girl I don't know
if you're going to read that she said oh
the video footage didn't show him
pinching my butt that was later that's
not true that's not true
well it's an extraordinary interview uh
and it's the first one he's given since
his conviction it's going to air in full
tomorrow night you can make your own
mind up about Cuba Gooding Jr when you
watch it but joining me now is the
Superstar women's rights lawyer Gloria
Ulrich Laurie great to have you on Piers
Morgan uncensored interviewed you many
times over the years thank you for
inviting me listen what do you feel
about this hey what do you feel about
Cuba Gooding Jr doing an interview with
me
well that's a scoop for you I'm looking
forward to seeing it uh I did represent
uh Ms Harbert but that was after uh
there was an agreement by the district
attorney uh in Manhattan to allow Mr
Gooding Jr uh to enter a plea of guilty
to one victim uh for forcible touching
but then the condition was that of The
Plea that if he didn't get arrested for
the next six months uh after the plea
that the forcible touching would be
reduced to harassment which is not a
crime in New York should be but it's not
uh and then he he would have no criminal
record whatsoever this is outrageous uh
uh appears because there were more than
30 women that contacted uh the district
attorney in New York many of whom were
willing to testify either as alleged
victims or as what we call prior bad act
or they call it New York Molino
Witnesses sometimes we call it me too
Witnesses and the idea that he should
leave all of this with no criminal
record I think is a demonstration that
with this new district attorney in New
York not the one but prosecuted Harvey
Weinstein but a new one that there are
two standards of Justice one for
celebrities and one forever
built the other side of this to you
which is that ultimately this is the
deal that he was offered and the offense
which he pleaded guilty was I would I
mean it's not for a man to say this
maybe you could attest to this either
way but the actual thing that he
admitted to on the me too scale seemed
at the lower end of sexual assault he
kissed a waitress on the lips not to
diminish in any way what happened that
he admitted to a criminal offense but he
wasn't charged with any other offenses
and his argument to me and I give him
quite a hard time in the interview and
his argument is look I've admitted my
wrongdoing I went through a very bad
period where I was drinking too much
partying too much and you know just
doing stupid things in nightclubs and I
wish I hadn't done it deep regret very
sorry but I wanted I want a second
chance I guess my question for you
Gloria is given that that was the only
offense he's been convicted of
should he not be entitled to Redemption
have we lost that ability to have people
allowed to have Redemption
okay well Redemption is a religious
concept I'm a lawyer I deal with Justice
issues and the idea is that if women
have been victimized and if the district
attorney believes that that case can be
proven Beyond A Reasonable Doubt which
was the decision of the prior district
attorney who's no longer the district
attorney and that's why he was charged
with three crimes against different
women uh three women one each uh then I
think there should have been a trial I
think that those who were alleged to be
victims by the prior da should have been
able to have their day in court at a
trial and then whatever the jury decided
the jury would decide and if they
convicted him he should face the
consequences he should even face the
consequences for the one forcible
touching right that he admitted to well
he's in court
there really are no consequences for
Forum well the consequence can be
certainly for now the consequence can be
you watch the whole interview when it
airs tomorrow and I get you back on next
week and we discuss what you thought of
it deal
that's a deal absolutely I accept your
invitation I look forward to it and by
the way I have a civil lawsuit pending
against Mississippi I know you do and
we'll discuss that on behalf of my
client when I get you back Glory we'll
discuss that I would love to get your
assessment of the interview once you've
watched it so we'll talk to you next
week thank you very much indeed for
joining me we'll do it thank you well
you can watch that full interview with
Cuba Gooding Jr his first interview
since his conviction here's a look at
what's to come
I will not ever let negativity stop the
god-given energy that I have there
seemed to just be a pattern of of claims
he robbed his groin and pelvis hard
against a button put his hand on a
woman's buttocks and squeezed it without
a picture together bit a woman on her
shoulder twice and thrust his pelvis
against her I don't want anybody to feel
that they've been treated
inappropriately or harassed by me in any
way your words are not your words
they're someone else's and then that
becomes the headline there were a lot of
women who came forward who all made
claims it just didn't cross your mind
but your behavior was not inappropriate
[Music]
foreign
stuff and you can make your own mind up
when you watch it but next time I'll get
more reaction uh to what you've just
been listening to my Cuba Gooding Junior
with my pack that'll be after the break
[Music]
welcome back and with my sizzling pack
here I want to start with a little clip
of swella bravaman who is our home
secretary for the moment trying to
explain her own policy on Asylum
we have um an asylum system and people
can put in applications for Asylum how
would I do that well you can
um uh you can you can do it uh through
the safe and legal routes that we we
have what schemes open to me well if you
are able to get to the UK you are able
to put in an application for Asylum how
could I arrive in the UK if I didn't
have permission to get onto an aircraft
legally to arrive in the UK let me just
invite other colleagues if there's
anything they want to add
it's staggering well joining me now
taught to be a contributor Esther Krakow
times political sketchwriters Quentin
Latz Daily Mirror associate editor Kevin
McGuire a veritable Trifecta of geniuses
what do you have a Home Secretary who
literally has no idea what her own
Asylum policy is and she was given this
a situation of a 16 year old girl from
Africa seeking Asylum from you know
terrible conditions she had no idea how
she could get into the country she's
meant to be a lawyer right she's been
more worried she's meant to be the one
who knows knows a lot after pretty Patel
she got caught in a bit of um
hypothetical spaghetti uh it wasn't that
difficult but it was a hypothetical
correct and uh if you're a minister uh
when somebody puts up a hypothetical you
say I don't do hypotheticals because you
get lost in this spaghetti and that's
what happened to her today today I don't
think she's covered herself in glory but
I don't suppose it's going to uh worry
the conservatives that much because
it's a serious point because the more
that migration is talked about the less
label will want to talk about it they
just shut up
because the migrant crisis obviously
warring it's a big issue for most people
including conservatives I think she
should have been because she's not very
politically intelligent she obviously
didn't know how to brush up the question
but she should have said they can apply
to the safe and legal route and I admit
we don't have enough of those because
now at the moment you can only go to the
university here's my point it wasn't a
difficult question exactly no but she
was literally like a rabbit in
headlights unable to answer a simple
question and it was a question from a
conservative look it's well at
Brotherman will be out of a depth in
that glass of water and
she knows the boat people will keep on
coming if there is no safe and legal
route for those who are deemed to be
Asylum Seekers refugees when they're
here she won't stop the the salines
unless she allows them to claim on the
other side of the child yeah yeah I
don't think they've got a clue what
they're doing uh Tori and Pete Gareth
Johnson uh Quentin represents Dartford
has suggested the just stop oil
protesters should be classified as
terrorists let's listen to this
these people are not protesters they are
criminals
will the Prime Minister therefore
consider making just the oil a
prescribed organization so that they can
be treated as the criminal organization
they actually are
completely lunatic over the top uh
prescription is reserved for terrorist
groups uh you get as much as 14 years in
prison for belonging to a prescribed
group I can understand that he is cross
about these justices
that's what you reserve for really bad
terrorists is there any terrorism if
it's Islamic islamist terrorism
what they're doing is Terrorism they're
terrorizing the public and they're
putting people's lives well I would say
they're more paralyzing the public yeah
they're not terrorized
look he's a solicitor as well I mean
there seems to be quite a few of them
not engaging their brains properly there
is specific legislation against
terrorists whether it's the Islamic
State national action or far right group
Ira back in the day whoever it is they
kill and they maim these people are a
nuisance they protest they break the law
sometimes unquestionably they can be
tried you want to deal with them the
police need to get harder with them for
instance if they're on a Gantry keep the
cards I want to get a prediction from
the three of you uh and it's this I sent
this to secure stama last night at a
award show the sons who'd uh who cares
wins
is there any way labor don't win the
next election very quickly very likely
uh I think we're at one of those moments
like 1992 after black Wednesday no I
think he's but he's not complacent
that's what you will that's what he said
to me I think he is still beatable he
himself yeah because well in the
comments today he was completely
outsmarted by Rishi sunak soon that
looks younger and sparkier and sunac is
the most capable opponent he's faced I
think in a while we're looking at a hung
Parliament or conservative very slim
majority interesting well he certainly
thinks complacency is the enemy so that
is in his credit thank you Pat we're
terrific whatever you're up to keep it
unsensitive good night
foreign
[Music]